what's up
guys bang bang lunch money
time while wall street's trying to get
rich wrestlers just trying to get our
lunch money right i'm here finally she's
back
i'm back the beautiful intelligent
pelina eva lover marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
pimp what's up they look like michael
jackson today i don't know if you want
to look like michael jackson because he
was you know
unique but uh yeah sure talking about
style okay uh don't forget that lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
block five has three products you can
buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar alone
or you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in an interest bearing
account
go get a blockfy account blockfy.com
pomp it's awesome
blackfly.compomp what's up awesome
awesome okay the election is tomorrow
there's not much to say except that the
election race remains tight
between trump and biden so it's
it's going to be one of them there's not
going to be a surprise
third horse in the race just saying
what i will say about the election is
regardless of if trump or biden wins
remember one thing
the government and no politician on this
planet
are coming to save you you are
responsible for you
educate yourself take control of your
life
don't wait around for people to give you
things or for the government to
tell you what to do or say that you're
allowed to do things
simply remember that personal
responsibility
will set you free it's not that hard
there's no political candidate that's
going to save you
or that's going to make you rich or
successful or happy
in fact they're probably going to do the
opposite so take
responsibility understand what you're
trying to do
and go do it stop waiting around
hoping that some government is going to
come and solve your problems
they ain't coming they don't care about
you they're not going to fulfill their
campaign promises
they're all the same yeah that really
sucks because some people really do
vote for people based on their campaign
promises and then it's like oh sorry i
didn't have time for that
you can be a sheep and you can hang your
dreams on campaign promises
or you can be a [ __ ] savage and go to
work every day and say
i'm gonna do the things i need to do to
make sure i'm healthy
wealthy and wise you sound like my
fourth grade teacher
okay it's just true guess what because
at the end of the day there's a lot of
people in this country
who genuinely believe the government
will solve their problems
the government doesn't give a [ __ ] about
you
and that's okay their job is actually
not to give a [ __ ] about you
i think their job is to give a [ __ ]
about them no it's not
the government is not there to solve
your problems
they want you to think that they want to
tell you they're going to give you free
money
and free this and free that they ain't
going to do anything
and it doesn't matter who's in office
this is very uplifting thank you
just take responsibility for yourself
that's it okay that's what i have to say
about the election
can we just reflect that he used the
words healthy wealthy and wise
yeah early to bed early to rise keeps a
man healthy wealthy and wise
leave a comment if you know who said
that quote you never heard that before
yes i have just didn't think i would
hear it on lunch money here today but
here we are well sorry that i'm educated
the soap opera that was the
deal the luxury deal uh between lvmh
and tiffany lvmh was supposed to acquire
tiffany but then there was a bunch of
drama
when lvmh in september went public with
the news that the french government
asked it to wait on closing the deal
so now they have finally settled on
terms it's going to be it's still going
to be the
largest deal in luxury retail
lvmh will acquire tiffany for 131
dollars and 50 cents a share that's 3.50
less than the original price but one 50
more than tiffany's reported bottom line
well they got it through consolidation
every time that there's economic damage
you're going to get consolidation and
that's what you're seeing here makes
sense
cool by the way i don't know what any of
that is what is
lvmh it stands for something i cannot
pronounce
but what is it it's a luxury they got
clothes they got bags they got shoes
what they got
oh all that yeah i never heard of it
they ever heard of nike
go ahead inspire brands will
buy duncan brands group for 8.8 billion
setting up one of the largest restaurant
deals in years as some in the industry
think beyond the coronavirus pandemic
what are these large deals why are they
happening during 2020 what is happening
because whenever there is chaos there's
opportunity
so you get either assets that are
distressed these aren't distressed
assets but you get distressed assets
which leads to consolidation
you get people who say you know what
while all my competitors are reeling i'm
actually going to go
gain market share i'm going to get
aggressive i have access to capital if
you have a lot of capital now is a good
time probably
exactly but remember america runs on
dunkin
dunkin donuts poppin today
anthony got me coffee and it was the
wrong coffee
false i know false i got up
like i do every morning and i went and i
got coffee for you me
and the wind is really strong somebody
else and
when i did that they gave me the cup
and they said what was in there is what
i ordered and then i handed it to you
and it wasn't there so either i
magically changed it on the way
or they gave me the wrong thing did you
magically change it on the way
no all right i'm like david copperfield
though
who it's all right um you're not
cultured go ahead
square square
is looking so you know square it's an
electronic payment system operator
it's in talks to purchase the tax
preparation business
of personal finance company credit karma
what does square want to do with
tax preparation square's entire business
has always been around payments deposits
uh point-of-sale systems etc anything to
do with payments square wants to own
uh and so if you're involved in payments
then you're going to also
have uh your customers want you to help
them with taxes
right if i'm if i'm constantly
processing payments i'm going to somehow
need to
get that information in an automated
fashion into my taxes
and so if you've got something that can
do that yeah that's uh
really attractive for businesses small
business or personal right like imagine
if
you do a ton of um you know payments or
whatever i don't know why somebody would
be doing a ton of payments on cash app
uh that would need to be reported on
their taxes but maybe
um okay so the pandemic has wiped out
millions of mostly low-income jobs in
hotels restaurants retail and other
hard-hit corners of the economy
but now they're moving into higher paid
office workers
in the last few days exxon mobil chevron
charles schwab and
raytheon have announced plans to cut
thousands of white-collar jobs
that's on top of major layoffs already
announced
at wells fargo goldman sachs salesforce
allstate and cnn owner
warner media nobody is safe if you think
you're safe you're not safe
yeah i mean it's very easy when a
restaurant shuts down and say hey we
have to fire our staff
like that's like a cause effect very
very very simple to understand
what now you're starting to see is uh
companies say wait a second maybe this
is gonna last much longer than we
thought we should go ahead and cut cost
we also are starting to understand like
maybe we didn't need all of these people
here
uh there's many people who are sitting
at home who if you're intellectually
honest with yourself
you're going into work let's say a nine
to five for eight hours a day
and maybe you've been told to stay home
or you were told to stay home for some
period of time
and you realize actually i only do like
two or three hours worth of work
like i can basically get it done in
three hours people
well if you think about like one of my
brothers is a great example right like
he used to go into a job every single
day now he still
is spending his time doing his work all
that kind of stuff but like if he just
sits down
and focuses uh he can get it done in
like three or four hours
so like there's a whole bunch of other
stuff that goes on in the office that
isn't direct
output of work right right and there's a
lot of distractions and
in-person meetings that waste a ton of
time and snacks
and lunch breaks and people walking by
your desk and you're constantly like
okay
yeah well the other piece of it too is
like i think there's a lot of people who
are suffering
right now because uh they don't have
that interaction with people right so
like the mental health
uh is gonna take a toll on that um
there's people who just
they they need to get out of their house
right they need to go into an office and
so
uh there's different things happening
around the world and also in the united
states but
in new york if you walk down the street
on you know eight nine o'clock in the
morning there used to be
thousands thousands of men and women
dressed up ready to go to their
corporate job suits ties briefcases now
we're just seeing sweatpants all over
the place what do they call a pantsuit
for women right like all that stuff
okay no that's what they call it right
sure okay no that is what they call it
i'm pretty sure i'm a fashion
expert uh when is the last time you saw
a woman wear a pantsu
on the streets of new york city uh this
morning
literally at starbucks but there's just
not that many of them anymore so
i think that there's a very direct
line between the number of people i see
in suits ties in briefcases
and the economic recovery in new york
city great
all right why is it so windy oh my god
it opened the door
well because the wind is blowing oh my
god okay
all right so we're just gonna let that
happen um the door's open right now
i'm gonna get swept away next thing you
know
wuhan china
where the coronavirus is said to have
originated is the latest
destination for dark tourism trips dark
tourism is basically like when people go
to these
tragic sites and tour it
oh my god um so um
basically a bunch of people are now very
curious about the deadly viruses initial
focal point
and a bunch of them are flying to wuhan
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna talk about
i'm not gonna talk about the origination
of the virus but we should check the lab
uh but what i will say is that um
this makes a lot of sense because one
they've cleared it of coronavirus
they've basically said there's no corona
virus after a 76 day
lockdown yeah and uh that ended in april
they were literally having
concerts and water pool parties
just google wet and wild wuhan and you
guys are gonna see photos
they had a concert and everyone's in a
pool there's like hundreds if not
thousands of people there it's
absolutely wild
uh but if you can go to a
uh a safe place where there is no virus
now is there actually no virus i don't
know that's what's being reported
um but it's kind of like a you know when
a crime occurs if there's a shooting
where's the safest place to be right
after a shooting it's actually at the
crime scene that's where the cops are
right similar here is if that is where
it originated
check the lab uh and you want to go
somewhere that is the safest
actually probably wu on china is
probably one of the safest places in the
world from the virus i probably wouldn't
be caught at a wet and wild environment
that's a difference
that's a difference but yes i hear you
um okay
i have a joke for you um it comes from a
lunch money viewer i don't know if their
name their username is inappropriate i'm
going to say it anyway uh wait
real quick wet and wild i feel like this
is like a cultural difference
where i thought wet and wild was like uh
they would
advertise these videos at like two or
three a.m
uh and they were like uh spring break
they'd go to spring break and they would
get like drunk people in like bikinis
and stuff yeah
all right just very different cultural
things like in the us you can't call it
wet and wild i don't think i don't think
that's a thing
i don't think they called it wet and
well i think we called it wet and wild i
think it's called like uh
all right that makes more sense go ahead
sorry
cultural differences yeah it's just like
maybe they're just using terminology
that
they don't you know it's like a
different thing there like maybe guys
save me help me okay wet and wild wuhan
is like that's
pretty man spring break
sell some tickets all right
we know what you're doing at 3 a.m what
t-shirt contest
that's what they used to have on yeah
that's what they used to have on it
somebody
somebody go find the link for me i don't
know there's like videos i'm telling you
we we know what that is that's a thing
right right
we don't want to talk about it right now
okay i'll stop talking about wet and
wild video series
i think the guy who made it got sued
okay ready
yeah so um i don't know if this is an
inappropriate
username or not but i'm just gonna say
hex princess
on twitter i don't know what that means
um
okay so here's our joke why doesn't
superman
sell bitcoin after 7pm
why because it's crypto night
i will pay somebody a hundred dollars if
they send in a joke that makes me laugh
oh come on because these jokes aren't
funny all right that's it for lunch
monday today guys
wet and wild wuhan and personal
responsibility that's what you guys get
at lunch money
we'll see you guys tomorrow see ya bang
bang hope you guys enjoyed this episode
of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends